Marta Un saludo para usted una mañana
muy ocupada desde el inicio Así es
Ángela Buenos días Bueno le voy a pedir
que empiece sin tardar con sus temas
vamos a hacer un resumen y más adelante
vamos a volver al análisis sobre la
entrevista de Manuel macron perfecto
Ángela Pues nosotros teníamos un tema
que también está candente la agenda hoy
que es el tema de Boris Johnson y la
audiencia que tiene lugar esta mañana a
partir de las 9 de la mañana de aquí
hora Bogotá en Reino Unido sobre el
famoso escándalo del partygate ayer el
party por recordar es este nombre que
recibe las fiestas encuentros y
reuniones que tuvieron los miembros del
gobierno de Boris Johnson mientras
regían las estrictas normas por el
confinamiento de la pandemia de covid-19
todo esto fue en 2020 y 2021 después de
meses de investigación de su propia
caída como Primer Ministro este
miércoles tiene lugar esta audiencia
clave que puede determinar un poco el
futuro de Boris Johnson ayer antes el ex
Premiere su escrito de defensa de 52
páginas en la que reconocía haber
mentido al parlamento sobre estas
reuniones porque en algún momento Ángela
recordemos que llegó a decir que todo
era falso en las declaraciones que dijo
y que en las que negaba todo esto Dijo
sin embargo que las hizo de buena fe un
dato curioso que muestra el periódico de
Guardian Es que la defensa de Johnson
está costeada con dinero público y se
han dejado más de 200.000 libras en todo
esto hoy a las 2 de la tarde hora local
empieza esta audiencia y el comité de
privilegios de la cámara de los comunes
ha presentado Ya esta mañana un
documento sobre las pruebas si este
decide que hubo un engaño deliberado por
parte de Johnson podría terminar su
periodo como diputado en la cámara de
los comunes un castigo fuerte esto era
lo que decía de Guardian sin embargo
tras toda esta información que usted nos
cuenta evidentemente las portadas de los
periódicos en el país son casi que
monográficas no cuentan todos pendientes
lo que va a pasar con Boris Johnson
Ángela y bueno Pues al calor un poco de
ese escrito de defensa todas las
portadas hoy reflejan este tema
empezamos también así mismo condegar y
en que titula Johnson enfrenta una pelea
por su supervivencia política en la
audiencia del parque también destacamos
la portada de independent donde se ve a
Boris Johnson brindando con esa copa de
vino en noviembre de 2020 En una de esas
reuniones y titula así de Independencia
el ex Premier admite que mintió aunque
no intencionadamente y nadie le dijo que
beber vino en los eventos del 10 de Down
Street rompía las reglas una defensa
plausible para el bombazo piramidal de
Boris hemos destacado también el Herald
scotland con esa cita que dice mentí al
parlamento pero no deliberadamente el
daistar este Bueno este tabloide
famosísimo en Reino Unido titula Pinocho
y hace un montaje del Primer Ministro
con esa nariz kilométrica que dice no
soy mentiroso Solo soy idiota Y por
último destacamos la portada de metro
que dice no eran auténticas barbaridades
y se ve esa misma foto de Boris
brindando y no justo detrás de usted
estamos viendo la de estar y ya vamos a
ver la de metro entonces bueno está
complicada la cosa eso Es evidente ha
generado mucha polémica además ha habido
muchas mentiras y muchas falsedades y
todo se va a dirimir o sea el comité va
a dirimir su bueno su conclusión final
después de la Pascua Y entonces se verá
si Boris sigue o no como diputado en el
parlamento británico en todo caso si lo
suspenden por más de 10 días Lo que
veremos será una elección en su
circunscripción vamos a cambiar de tema
Marta de la cadena estadounidense CNN
publicaba la jornada de ayer una
exclusiva sobre un presunto crimen de
guerra ruso en la ciudad de issume en
Ucrania donde un soldado del kremlin
está acusado por este delito por intento
de asesinato contra un civil está toda
la historia así es Ángela y nos
referimos a que la bueno la defensa y
los tribunales ucranianos van a acusar
de hecho lo hicieron ayer era un soldado
ruso por crímenes de guerra en Rebeldía
en Rebeldía porque el soldado acusado no
está presente físicamente tras la
acusación todo esto por intento de
asesinato contra un civil ucraniano la
ciudad de izum en el mes de junio
que ciudad que recordemos está en la
región de jarquiz que al final ha sido
uno de los epicentros de las tensiones
militares desde el inicio de la guerra
ayer antes de que la policía de harquiz
filtrara esta acusación le pasó todo
este documento a la cadena
estadounidense CNN como decimos el
intento de asesinato según recoge la
cadena es un delito penado en el código
penal ucraniano por crimen de guerra
toda la investigación se pudo llevar a
cabo interceptando llamadas telefónicas
del soldado ruso con su mujer y con un
amigo en la que decía textualmente que
había matado a un [__] hombre ucraniano
y que no sabía quién era la
particularidad de todo esto es que todo
el momento y toda la escena fue grabada
por un
como estas historias hemos visto muchas
a lo largo de este primer año de guerra
Cuál es la historia muy rápidamente
Marta que hay detrás de todo este asunto
como decimos todo fue en junio del año
pasado una pareja viajaba en un coche a
la ciudad de izum para evacuar a los
padres de él de esa ciudad que entonces
era víctima de los bombardeos rusos en
el trayecto la pareja se equivoca de
camino y es alcanzada por las bombas
rusas los soldados ucranianos captan
toda la escena con los drones en las
imágenes se ve a esta pareja intentando
salir del coche y en esa en esa intento
de huida vuelven a ser atacados y el
hombre queda gravemente herido Entonces
ella empieza a mover al esposo detrás
del carro
a taparle las heridas con toallas los
soldados ucranianos están viendo todo
con el dron pero no se pueden acercar
porque los rusos están muy cerca de la
pareja Entonces se les ocurre poner un
cartel en el dron que dice sígueme sobre
todo para que ella pudiera ponerse a
salvo porque no estaba herida tiempo
después ella relata me di la vuelta caí
de rodillas y chillé con El grito más
agonizante No sabía de quién era el dron
si de nuestras fuerzas o del enemigo
finalmente siguió al dron y al final el
chico que fue llevado a una zanja por
parte de los soldados rusos logró
sobrevivir tiempo después relata el
mismo que logró pedir ayuda y al final
todo salió bien pero ahora nueve meses
después pues siguen tratamiento por esas
heridas de metralla No pues es que es
una historia de terror Marta Le
agradezco mucho y nos vemos mañana
gracias Ángela